(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Hi, how are you?
- I'm good.
(audience cheering)
- Wait, we're coming up on Easter.
So do you do big things for
Easter with your family?
Do you have a big-
- Yeah, we have a big Easter service.
- Yeah, we do too.
- It's a big service for,
- You do the hunt?
Do you do like the Easter
egg hunt with like?
- Oh yeah, with the grand babies now,
the kids are all older, so they don't
- No with the grandkids, that's what
- Yes absolutely.
- Yeah, it's so fun.
It's like them finding it.
And then depending on the
age you have to make it
like super easy where you put the egg.
- Yeah. Well they they're just everywhere,
we have to do both.
'Cuz we we've covered the
ages there with the kids.
- I know.
That's I've had to do that as well.
So did you do anything for Lent?
- Yeah,
I didn't give up something.
I was going to give up wine.
- Yeah.
- And then you thought that's a bad idea.
- Dumb
- That just don't make sense.
I'm pretty sure God
wants me to drink wine.
- Yeah. He turned,
it was his idea, water into wine.
- Yeah, that's right.
- That's on him.
- At that wedding, remember,
we need more.
- Yes. And also it's good for your heart,
if you're drinking red.
- My doctor said two glasses of night.
So I thought this is medical.
I shouldn't do this,
probably not good.
- You know what my mother says,
my mother used to say
"Shema", she's from Boston,
she'd say "Shema, one bottle
of wine is only two glasses".
(laughing)
- How big is her
- That's a big glass.
- She has like a vat of wine.
I love it.
So wait, so the new
show looks very intense.
I love a competition series.
So it's called "Beyond The Edge".
So what's happening?
- Okay. So they've taken nine celebrities,
people who live a fairly
comfortable life and stuck 'em
in the middle of some of
the most beautiful country
and beautiful and brutal
country in the world in Panama.
In the jungles of Panama
and said, Hey, good luck survive.
And oh, and by the way,
every day we're going to do a
something similar to a triathlon.
- Oh my gosh.
Did you have to get in
shape for it or anything?
Like I would never sign up for that.
- We did.
- I would,
that sounds like fat camp.
I was like, great.
That sounds like, hard.
- You know Lauren Alaina,
I said I was fortunate
'cause, just prior to this,
I was literally training for an Ironman.
So I felt like I was in
great shape. I'm good.
Plus, I've been to Panama,
I've been there before.
- Oh yeah, you've been in the army.
- I was in the army, stationed there.
So I knew a lot about the environment
the animals and everything.
Lauren says her training.
She went from the couch to the jungle.
- Oh my God.
See she's me, yeah.
- Just jump in,
just to hell,
why not?
- It was absolutely amazing though.
It's funny when you take people,
I don't care where they're
from what their background is,
their race, religion, creed
and how much money they make or anything,
and you stick 'em in an
environment like that.
All of that other stuff that
we kind of hold important
as we meet and see each other
goes away.
- Yeah.
- None of that stuff matters anymore.
It's all about the heart
and the mind and the soul.
- So wait, are y'all helping others?
- Yes! So this show is not
like a normal survivor show
where everybody's a survival
show where people are trying to
get each other off.
- Yeah
- Our objective here was
for everyone to stay.
So every day we stayed,
we raised more money
for our charities.
And if you won an event and
the team kind of changed up
so you never really could
work with someone to
try to figure out how you can stay on.
You just work as hard as you
can and win as much money
as you can for the charity.
Ultimately there will be one person who
made the most money.
- Yeah.
- But the concept was, everybody wins.
It's up to you.
You're the one that has to
make the decision to leave.
And you know, you, it's just the, again
the camaraderie that was established.
- Yeah.
- These people are
my friends for life now.
Oh, that's so cool.
I mean we stay and people I
might not have otherwise met.
- Yeah.
- Paulina.
I mean, she's a supermodel
and I call my wife and
I'm like, you know, after
- Oh how did that go over?
Hey, I'm, I'm surviving in the
wilderness with a supermodel.
- Yeah. We couldn't talk
to the while we were there.
- Okay.
- When it was over
and I finished and I called
her like, Hey, I'm headed home.
And I met this lady.
She's a model, Paulina.
And I can't pronounce her last name.
And my wife's like,
she's a one name person.
You don't need to know her last name.
- Oh my God.
- And she's like, well
would, and she was beautiful.
I don't mean I'm not just
- Aesthetically. Not just aesthetically.
- Yes, her heart was so beautiful.
And I don't think that she
and I would've ever met
had it not been for the show.
- That's cool.
- And I just fell in love with her
and these people and we're
friends for life now.
- Oh, that's so cool.
Yeah. Can we come back to
the part where you said
that you were training for
an Ironman before this, like
is this like a normal thing
your family does, like
y'all do very athletic things or you all?
- We are.
- You are?
- My family's very, my
daughter and my son-in-law,
my son-in-law just qualified.
Well, he qualified a year ago for Kona
and they keep putting it
off because of the COVID.
- I can never be a member of your family.
I would not fit.
I would be the water girl.
I'll show up with signs, supportive signs.
That's amazing that you're a grandpa
cuz I saw this video and
I want to show this video.
I don't even know, if
I'm supposed to show
you, but I wanna show it.
It's so, so cute.
So you spoil them with sugar
and your daughter doesn't like it, right?
- No, they're super healthy.
We're all super healthy eaters.
But you know
- Not says this powdered donut goal
- Every now and then a kid
deserves a powdered donut
to experience it.
- and adults.
- And adults, yeah.
- Let's see the tape.
- (laughing) It's so good.
(cheering)
- I love it.
This is what's amazing.
I feel like I still
get that same like whoa
with sugar and so good and mad for you.
But I love that you're grandpa,
you're allowed to spoil a little bit.
I think so.
- Yes, we do.
I think we're supposed to, you know,
it's like you have all of the same things
that you had with the
kids without any guilt.
- Yeah.
- And I don't feel bad
giving him a sugar donut.
- And you're not gonna
have to take care of them
when they're wild.
- Yeah, he won't go to sleep, honey.
- Here you go. You put
your time in, I did.